it is said that by 2050 world population
will increase substantially right now
our numbers range around 7 billion
people by 2050 it is projected to be
around 9 billion about 70 percent of
these 9 billion will be inhabiting the
urban landscape these cities will not
only have to be groundbreaking but they
will be built to face the ongoing
housing crisis this is why as of now the
world's most reputed Specialists are
designing and building cities in order
to take us safely into the Future these
are the cities of the future One luju
Forest City China a true model City for
the future of the planet luju Forest
City China's first vertical Forest City
has been under construction since 2020
designed by Italian architect Stefano
boering the creator of the vertical
forest in Milan the Forest City will
work as a sustainable element in China
able to absorb tons of CO2 producing
oxygen while battling the smog affected
regions of the mountainous South who
have been in suffering the consequences
of overpopulation and air pollution for
Generations as its name suggests it is a
city where everything will be covered
with trees and plants the minimalist
design buildings will be able to draw
geothermal energy for its own heating
and cooling system solar panels will be
installed on rooftops to gather
renewable energy the entire city will be
connected through a fast rail line and a
road set up exclusively for the use of
electric powered cars it will house
several residential areas commercial
spaces recreational facilities Public
Services two schools and a hospital
China has already commissioned several
vertical Forest areas in its territory
in order to absorb carbon dioxide
emissions from the mainland these Forest
cities will also create natural noise
barriers protect biodiversity decrease
temperatures and improve air quality
altogether there's already a population
of 500 people living in nuju Forest City
but it will house over thirty thousand
people forty thousand tree and thousands
of plants of different species 2. net
City China tencent China's main
technology company has always been an
investor in new gadgets and plans for
the near future net City could prove to
be their most important work the concept
lies in the fact that most cities
operate around automobile traffic net
City will prioritize Logistics regarding
people and environment net City's goal
is to eliminate cars completely
centering its effort on a green Corridor
designed only for buses pedestrians
bikes and autonomous vehicles the scale
height and spacing of buildings will
provide ample site to Natural spaces and
the Waterfront which will be an integral
component to the city this city is
currently being constructed in a 2
million square meter of an empty
landfill in the province of Shenzhen
developed by American company nbbj it
will be a sustainable futuristic city
that will completely serve Innovation
ecological self-sufficiency education
and professionalism it will primarily
serve as a hub for 10 cents employees
there will be Sky Gardens grass-covered
rooftops solar panels and Wastewater
capturing systems exteriors will be
filled with smart sensors to control the
environment and public transport which
will be implemented by train subway
several Bridges and an outgoing Highway
green power will provide for the entire
energy demand of the city most of the
spaces will be meant for human
interaction residential areas malls and
stores recreational zones Natural Parks
and tree lines schools business areas
entertainment zones and ample spaces
where exercising will be specially
stimulated as it increases the
productivity and health of the employees
10 centers already announced that they
expect the city to start functioning by
early 2027. 3. Chengdu future City China
it started as an expansion of Chengdu
City but it quickly became more than
that construction on Chengdu future city
began in 2021 by German Studios GMP and
the Dutch firm Oma it is a sustainable
car free District that focuses on the
site's natural topography and geography
for its development the vast valleys and
mountains of Chengdu will be preserved
enhanced and shaped in order to create
and maximize space new smart buildings
will be clustered into the hills to
populate the skyline and everything will
be connected through Bridges and small
corridors that will also be sculpted
around the natural topography the city
is planned to be the home of ample
minded dedicated professionals attracted
to Innovation and will emphasize on the
existence of universities Laboratories
offices workshops libraries and learning
residences an entire building will be
dedicated for the sole use of research
and innovation in food and agriculture
Chengdu future city will be divided into
six sectors the government cluster the
public cluster the market cluster the
laboratory cluster the university
cluster and the living cluster these
car-free clusters will all be connected
by trains and smart Mobility networks
for automated Vehicles as with other
green cities planned by the government
of China Chengdu future city aims for
sustainable energy while integrating it
completely into an urban technocratic
development 4. woven City Japan Toyota
Motor Corporation the giant Japanese
automobile manufacturer has been
transitioning from the automotive park
to a mobility and Robotics company for
years now their implementation of smart
houses in Japan has already borne
positive fruits woven City gets its name
regarding the concept of a city inside
another city made of interwoven streets
that also establish a transportation
pattern one street dedicated to
automated driving another Street to
pedestrians and a last one for personal
Mobility Vehicles it started
Construction in 2021 in the foothills of
Mount Fuji at the susano city's former
Toyota plant empty terrain of 100 175
Acres the study and testing of
Technology robotics artificial
intelligence smart mobility and
automated driving will be the main
mission of this community special
emphasis will be made in robotics for
day-to-day tasks and home appliances at
first woven City will house 360 people
that will most likely consist of
researchers Toyota employees and elderly
people they will get to experiment test
and develop these advances and
appliances for real-world usage their
inputs will contribute to the Future
residents that aspire to be of at least
2 000 people Danish architect biaka
Ingalls creator of the Lego House of
California spearheads the design and
part of the plans are to energize the
city with a hydrogen fuel cell system
fully integrated with the ecosystem
roofs will be covered in solar panels
and wood will be the primary
construction material for houses 5.
Amara TV India India has a plan to fight
their constant overpopulation by 25 50
843 million people are expected to live
in urban areas the solution a nationwide
plan to build a hundred smart cities by
2030. some of them will be new cities
constructed from scratch and some older
existing cities will be upgraded with
modern technology such is the case of
Amara TV the new capital and
administrative city of India set on the
banks of the river Krishna this historic
City and its monuments will be preserved
while transitioning towards modernity
and the automation age the whole city
will grow around a needle-top government
building and more than 60 percent of the
territory will be occupied by Greenery
and water in order to make Amara TV one
of the most sustainable cities in the
world Transportation will consist of
electric vehicles Metro rails buses
powered by electricity or clean fuel
cycling and pedestrian routes and Water
Taxis as its waterfront measures around
27 kilometers there will be no electric
wires or overhead mobile Towers in fact
the city plans to implement India's
latest technology the conversion of
light into electricity through
photovoltaics all of it stored in an
underground power grid India's
government claims to develop hamara TV
with the citizens happiness as its main
concern inhabitants of Amara TV will
enjoy 100 Wi-Fi signal at all times plus
affordable housing plans 6. Maldives
floating city the Maldives Indian Ocean
maldivian government has known for a
while that climate change will make the
sea levels rise and completely swallow
more than 80 percent of the country by
2050. therefore the Maldives floating
city was conceived the First floating
city of the world will house around 20
000 people by 2027 and it will follow
the design of the brain corals that can
be found underwater this completely
eco-friendly project will provide the
sea level rise problem with a practical
solution the science of it is simple the
construction of around 5000 floating
structures attached to a hexagonal
built-in system that'll float as the
Seas rise the town's idiosyncrasies will
follow native customs of the Maldives by
enhancing marine life and preserving the
ecosystem through the use of sustainable
Technologies the city will be located
inside a ring of barrier islands that
will serve as Breakers as well as the
coral formations which will be preserved
as a natural defense of the island and
the structural stabilization for housing
this project is a joint venture between
the maldivian government and Dutch
developers Dutch docklands with design
from Architecture Firm water Studio
which have already built floating Parks
floating dairy farms and floating
offices in the Netherlands the city will
be designed to be attractive for
inhabitants and tourists alike following
caribbean-style rainbow colored homes
with balconies porticos and seafront
Views the first units will be completed
this year and the first residence will
be located in 2024 7. new Taipei City
Taiwan Taiwan is a country that lives in
the future today its flag project is new
Taipei City built around the capital
city and has become the preferred space
to make business in Taiwan the
technology industry is quite active
attracting and concentrating a
considerable amount of Workforce
Employment and opportunities in new
Taipei City this is why the region has
been transitioning to becoming a smart
City since early 2016. the city's
government has achieved it by rewarding
practices in urban sustainability and
citizen participation their energy
policy is Guided by The Net Zero 2050
goals where all carbon emissions will be
down to zero smart cities need smart
citizens as much as technology and
Robotics this is why new Taipei City
citizen culture has made it the city of
the future for instance there is an app
for pollution prevention that provides
citizens the ability to report any kind
of pollution they witness in any part of
town the city not only channels every
government service via real-time apps
but smart Mobility is already in
practice sensors and smart
infrastructure are currently being
implemented in the streets starting to
monitor real-time traffic situations and
offering citizens alternatives to avoid
traffic jams these same monitors and
sensors have also been useful in crime
tracking contributing to the town's
integral security and police activities
new Taipei City expects to be one of the
leading smart cities in the world and a
symbol of the transition to the Future
8. new santara Indonesia recent Studies
have concluded that some areas in
Indonesia will be completely underwater
by 2050. one of these areas involves
Jakarta Indonesia's present capital city
in order to seize their future and plan
accordingly Indonesia's government has
implemented its project since 2019 a new
planned city nusantada the new capital
city of Indonesia strictly conceived
towards relieving the pressures of
overcrowding pollution and the
progressive sinking of the present
capital Jakarta 33 billion dollars will
be spent on this new metropolis and the
relocation of the capital will take
decades to complete construction started
in 2022 and the plan is to set the
inauguration in 2024 towering High
skyscrapers will use 100 renewable
energy there will be lots of green
spaces as the city will be surrounded by
jungle and rainforest where the
eucalyptus tree is inherent to the
ecosystem Mobility will consist of short
distances where public transport cycling
and walking will be the norm a Metro
System of two Rail lines autonomous
minibuses and a bus rapid transit system
will be the means of transportation as
most destinations are located 15 minutes
away from the residential zones
nusantada will focus on the livability
adequate infrastructure and thriving
economic environment as Indonesia's
economy is rapidly growing 9. new
administrative Capital Egypt a very
similar case occurs with Egypt's new
capital city yet to be named it is
referred to at the moment simply as the
new administrative capital or NAC as one
of the greatest capitals in the world
for its historical relevance Cairo is
quickly becoming chaotic and
unmanageable located 45 kilometers east
of Cairo the NAC has been under
construction since 2015. it will house
embassies government agencies the
parliament 30 Ministries a presidential
compound all operational by 2022 besides
21 residential districts the city will
also Harbor a Central Park artificial
Lakes stadiums educational institutions
churches hospitals a new airport 90
square kilometers of solar energy Farms
an electric Railway a monorail just
another Mega City from the future
Egypt's new smart city will be one of
the most technologically advanced ones
construction alone is reported to cost
around 45 billion dollars and it will
host 6.5 million people in a smart and
sustainable environment by 2050. the
whole Business Center is distributed
around a signature Skyscraper the iconic
Tower Africa's tallest skyscraper with a
height of
393.8 meters the NAC hopes to be
completely sustainable by 2050. every
Rooftop in the residential district will
have solar panels installed the city
will also Implement smart Waste
Management organic recycling facilities
smart climate metering smart irrigation
systems and new water treatment plants
the first phase of this city began
Construction in 2019 the energy plan has
proven effective as the solar panels
contribute 10 megawatts of electricity
to the government buildings in Egypt's
new capital city 10. eco-atlantic city
Nigeria Nigerian Economic Development
has been Unstoppable in recent years the
trend is that it will continue to become
one of the top 20 economies of the world
on top of 11 million square meters of
claimed land on the Atlantic Ocean a
man-made terrain eco-atlantic City will
will serve as the future Financial
capital of Africa it will be an urban
hub for commercial residential and also
tourist accommodations all built under
modern environmental standards the
development will also serve to assist
Lagos commercial activities as Nigeria
is one of the largest producers of oil
in the world but this city will also
serve towards the ecological needs of
Nigeria as it will be surrounded by an
eight kilometer long sea wall mostly
made out of rock in order to protect Eco
City and neighboring territories of the
dangers of erosion and also provide
defenses for any incoming High Tides Eco
City promises to be entirely powered by
renewable energy as it will exploit the
Everlasting amount of sunlight in the
region its skyscrapers will be equipped
with solar panels installed in the
rooftops and retractable Windows that'll
gather solar power as well the
residential areas are planned to be
powered by Hydro Energy new buildings
have been completed since 2020 and it is
projected that residents will amount to
250 000 and as steady flow of a hundred
and fifty thousand yearly tourists 11.
the amnientio Lake City Senegal Senegal
is another African country that's been
experiencing steady economic growth the
discovery of raw materials like oil and
gas have potentiated its economy and
hunger for progress in use and years
Dakar the country's capital has started
to pay the price of overpopulation so
the government's alternative to fight it
has been the construction of this
planned city that will alleviate dakar's
carbon footprint diabetio City will
extend for over 1 644 hectares and it
will be structured in three zones the
financial district offices universities
Ministries and hotels the residential
Zone with houses stores cafeterias
supermarkets and the Entertainment
District with malls fashion shops
libraries and theaters its architecture
will be styled as contemporary mixed
with abstractionism using African
influence arabesques and futuristic
herbs in its buildings these will be
built with glass iron copper and
concrete following the sustainable model
buildings will have green Gardens on the
roof and be powered by renewable energy
the train express Regional or ter will
be an electric train that'll operate
regionally and exclusively for this
Urban conglomerate a new smart
Expressway is also currently in
construction it will connect the city
with Dakar in 32 kilometers reducing the
normal travel time from 90 minutes to 30
12. neon aka the line Saudi Arabia
strictly out of a sci-fi movie The Line
refers to a linear settlement of a group
of buildings forming a straight line the
most unconventional and futuristic plant
smart future city is being built in neon
tabuk Province the encapsulated
structure covers an entire city built on
a desertic land that stretches out
towards the Red Sea as it elevates 500
meters above sea level in order to fully
enjoy nature without getting to impact
it directly as oil reserves of Saudi
Arabia are among the highest in the
world the idea of a sustainable covered
City comes up as a sustainable remedy a
city with no roads cars or carbon
emissions all powered by renewable
energy using a high-speed rail as the
main mode of transportation it is said
to accommodate 9 million people in
vertical layered homes skyscrapers
public parks and schools it will be
completely ecological with Open Fields
and natural spaces and self-sufficient
as it will Implement vertical farming
greenhouses cloud seeding water
desalination and robotic Urban
Development this will revolutionize
Saudi Arabia's entire existence as the
country currently Imports about 80
percent of its Foods weather control
will provide an ideal climate all year
round this Metropolis will extend 170
kilometers and it will have a width of
only 200 meters the city will be
organized by two parallel 500 meter high
linear skyscrapers standing 200 meters
apart from each other the line is the
the pet project of Saudi Prince Mohammed
bin Salman and the face of Saudi Vision
2030 a plan to diversify Saudi Arabia
and lessen its dependency on fossil
fuels 13. the orbit Canada the orbit is
Canada's answer to Future smart cities
located in the small town of Innisfil
its concept revolves around a smart
technocratic Society where the community
as a whole prioritizes environmental
sustainability the Arts Transit social
interaction health and wellness modern
economy modern agriculture Advanced
manufacturing all framed into a thriving
new energy culture it is the role model
for Suburban development the town is
organized around circular neighborhoods
designed to respond to a massive arrival
of human Transit that connects to
downtown Toronto the orbit a transformed
rural town will unite small town and
Rural Lifestyles all enhanced by the
benefits of sustainable Urban living
while preserving natural landscapes
agricultural lands forests natural
trails and historical buildings the
quote smart transformation will combine
it with a fiber optics Network
autonomous vehicles and drone ports this
fiber optic network will provide
connectivity across sidewalks streets
and buildings where all traffic
interaction will be monitored
Architecture Firm partisans claim that
the town's idea is influenced by The
Garden City movement of the early 20th
century that Advocates towards the union
of urban and agrarian life in the
outskirts agrarian activities and open
areas will be protected at all times
Transit will feature driverless vehicles
and ride-sharing pedestrian and cycling
routes a new Metrolink Station called Go
Transit will unite public and free
transportation and Link Toronto to the
town the orbit stretches out to 40
million square feet and it is designed
to house around 150
000 people in the future as Canada's
population will grow 55 by 2050 this
alternative to Urban living will
certainly have the lead 14. tell loser
United States a city planned for Utopia
telosi's name is derived from the Greek
word Telos which means purpose American
billionaire Mark law is spearheading
this effort to create the sustainable
City that will quotes set the global
standard for urban living though it will
be built somewhere in the American West
Desert telosa aims to house a population
of 5 million people by the year 2050. it
will be the epitome of the 15-minute
City where every essential human need
such as employment food education social
activities Leisure and nature spaces
will be close to home environment will
always be a priority so fossil fuel
vehicles won't be allowed electric cars
scooters bicycles and walkability will
be stimulated as well as slow-moving
autonomous vehicles the beacon of the
city will be a massive skyscraper dubbed
the equitism tower it will house a
massive water storage space aeroponic
farms and a photovoltaic roof city parks
and greeneries will be carefully managed
as reservoirs for storing water and
renewable energy and will also provide
for persistent open spaces for all
inhabitants waste will be stored
underground and every building will
serve as a vertical garden with wood as
the main building material their
philosophical and economical system will
be equitism an inclusive scheme in which
citizens have a stake in their land and
can have a say in the city's
decision-making process some of the
revenue from citizens will be invested
directly into the city's Public Services
their leaders have narrowed down that
its final location could be in Nevada
Utah or Arizona all of them deserted
areas by 2030 it is predicted that a
group of 50 000 people will be the first
residence of telosa 15. Starbase AKA
Starship Texas USA Elon Musk SpaceX and
Tesla's main man plans the construction
of a new smart city in the desertic
lands of Boca Chica Texas Starbase gets
its name precisely for being one of
spacex's launch sites and prototype
Laboratories since musk does not seem to
back off on his Innovative efforts
another city of the future has been born
at first it will house employees and the
people that work on launching sites in
the whole area as SpaceX has been
transforming the entire territory of
Boca Chica and surrounding areas of the
southern Texas coast into a conglomerate
for annual launches for Missions to the
moon and Mars Starbase hosts a gigantic
never-before-built rocket by the name of
Starship which is selected as the lunar
lander in NASA's Artemis program and a
future vessel to Mars missions many say
Starbase City will actually be a
rehearsal for musk's living quarters in
a terraformed planet for all of these
options efficiency will be priority
number one Renewable Power and tunneling
will be the core of the city's
functionality connectivity and energy
power won't be an issue for Starbase as
everything will be organized around the
launching site which will be in plain
sight for spectators and tourists to
witness regular rocket blast-offs it is
believed that by 25 50 Starbase will be
the departure point for commercial trips
to space in the world there will be no
streets roads or traffic an underground
network with autonomous electric
vehicles will transport everyone these
tunnels will be the only way in and out
of the city as it will also function as
a security element if any disaster
arises during a rocket launch 16. Smart
Forest City Mexico another future Smart
City from the mind of stefanoboeri
Mexico's first smart city is currently
being planned amid the most sought after
tourist site in the country Cancun it
isn't any news that tourist locations
leave an important ecological impact
wherever they are Cancun isn't an
exception for this that is why
Architects urbanists and designers are
proposing these kinds of projects in
order to balance the human footprint
within nature the smart Forest City's
objective is to balance Green spaces and
renewable energy sources by creating
self-sufficient cities it will be
completely surrounded by a ring of solar
panels and an underground irrigation
system that will allow the city to water
in a renewable method the Forest City
will contain 7.5 million plants of 400
different species all hand-picked by
landscape artist Laura Gatti the Forest
City will be able to absorb 116 000 tons
of carbon dioxide every year the design
of the city features a nurtured
Innovative Park as it will facilitate
spaces for universities organizations
labs and development companies that will
Research into more sustainable methods
for the planet's future Transportation
will demand that all fuel-powered cars
will be left outside of the city as
Mobility will be exclusively electric a
new transportation system has been
proposed as a chain Mobility method
completely powered by Electric
photovoltaic energy that will function
within City Limits this smart Forest
City will be able to host up to 130 000
people inside
557 hectares and it will Implement and
educate the world on how eco-friendly
tourist activity can be applied 17.
Helsinki bunker City Finland it is said
that Finland is the happiest country of
them all one of the reasons being that
their quality of life Spurs out of
mutual respect and honesty between its
citizens and environment which results
in an enriched quality of life but in
helsinki's future plans Warfare is a big
element for its City Planning with the
threat of Russia's military Powers
frowning at every neighboring country
that desires to join NATO Finland has
been building and populating its
underground city ready to resist any
attack almost every big structure in
Finland is required to have their own
bunker underneath in helsinki's
underground you will find a complex
system of more than 5 000 bomb shelters
able to withstand nuclear chemical and
Ray attacks extending all under the city
surface this underground system is
capable of housing 900 000 people and
it's already being used for gyms pool
facilities children's playgrounds Subway
ways and numerous tunnel communication
systems automatization and sensor
technology will not only prevent the
citizens from incoming attacks but for
natural disasters as well a conflict
with Russia seems to be a reality in the
near future the war with Ukraine has
taught them that much these underground
spaces are not the only defensive
efforts of the Nordic country Finland
has been raising a big army training its
men and implementing mandatory
recruitment every man woman or child is
being taught to act accordingly when an
attack begins dystopian reality is also
part of future city planning we hope
you've enjoyed this small leap into the
future as technology continues to expand
our future continuously changes so every
option is available for our future
cities day after day new projects for
future cities are created so by any
means the items in this list are just
the tip of the iceberg